in listening mode to over a hundred
local government leaders on the
coronavirus front line and we've got sky
with us for the first few contributions
Sky News joined a video call revealing
the challenges of the ongoing lockdown
first the care sector 5010 tests it's
just not happened then on council
finances ministers have been set to us
overtly three or four times
don't worry spend what it takes we will
reimburse you and we started to hear in
the last few days and particularly a
very concerning call with Nick leaders
yesterday on that commitment rapidly on
homelessness and supplies for the
vulnerable many of the food that was
being delivered it was over out of date
or close to being out of date moldy
bread has been being delivered to
residents which clearly is a real
concern and what was the lesson from the
discussion the governor's put a lot of
schemes in place and the question is how
they're being implemented in is there a
gap and we heard about real gaps one of
the starkest that I heard that was
enfield there enfield councils got 5,000
people working in the care sector and
they've only had ten tests opposing
maybe easy
but deciding is difficult does the
Labour leader think that ministers are
going to have to make trade-offs for
instance between young and old well I
don't think we'll be trade-offs as such
what we've got a duty to do is to keep
everybody safe and well that may be
putting in different support for
different sectors of course but it's not
really about a trade on but British
politicians never like to acknowledge
the trade-offs that they make in public
when they come to a decision and we've
seen that time and again from
politicians conservative as well as now
labour but the thing about the
coronavirus can
is that there are so many of them the
state of the economy under lockdown
versus the health of the nation
the young versus the old that's why one
cabinet minister said to me it was going
to take weeks to work out how to
convince the public that it might be
safe to come out of lockdown the chief
medical officer today saying that we are
reaching the peak but that might not be
enough at the moment we are not yet at
the point where we can say confidently
and safely this is now past the peak and
we can start thinking very much about
the next phases tomorrow a meeting of
Cobra likely to decide to continue
lockdown until at least the end of April
life slowing but ministers need to stop
too much coming to a complete halt
Sam Cote Sky News